[Music]
6 42
time for our morning cup of joe with
metro sheriff joe lombardo good morning
to you sheriff it's great to see you
hi alex hello uh we want to start with
this question sheriff there have been a
lot of burglaries recently on the west
side of town people are stealing
appliances from new homes before people
are moving into those homes so
do you have any suspect info at this
point and are they reselling those
appliances
yeah i wish i knew what they were doing
with them you know what we've
experienced
in the past and our you know police
knowledge on these kind of events
is they tend to take them out of state
and use different websites to get rid of
them
and or i guess you call them fences to
get rid of the stolen property
and more often than not they end up in
mexico so
there's a whole plethora of ways that
people can get rid of those
ill-gained items but in particular to
our issue we've had 27 plus
separate burglaries occur and they've
occurred mostly on the weekends
so if you are living adjacent to a new
home development
or you're living in the new home
development and houses are currently
under construction we ask the public to
be aware of this so the suspect
description on these is a
silver f-150 truck extended cab truck
and it occurs during the evening hours
on the weekends
and the truck would pull up to the front
of the house
they gain entry to the house and
set up their appliances by removing them
for wherever they're there they are in
the house
and set it up for another truck to come
by at a later period
and this is a big white panel truck that
backs into the driveway
and they put the appliances in that
truck and drive away
so i'm hoping there's somebody out there
in the public that'll see this
occurring and call us because right now
that's the most we have as far as leads
it's been posted on crime stoppers
385-5555
if you have the information and you want
to provide it
with anonymity associated with it if
it's more pressing like it's occurring
right in front of you
i i suggest you call 9-1-1 or 3-1-1 so
we can get there right away to
to address the issue yeah we have those
pictures of those vehicles for you to on
our website gosh the last thing you want
when you move into your new house is
your appliance is gone
all right yeah interesting enough we
have one of my my employees direct
employees that
that occurred to them they were getting
ready to move in the house next day and
they get in there and the house was
flooded because they separated the
refrigerator from the water system
and subsequently set them back a few
weeks so that's a big deal
how awful all right call crime stoppers
if you have any information
last week sheriff your officers were on
a call they were talking to a citizen
when someone started
shooting at them luckily they were not
hurt but obviously this is very
concerning
so when something like that happens does
metro implement any training or any
changes
yeah i mean that's a that's a great
question because it would be ignorant or
malpractice if we did
do something when we're aware of
something occurring we didn't make
adjustments in our training or how we
respond to calls
so similar to like one october it would
be malpractice if we didn't learn
something
from our failures there and then just
how we operate so in this case
officers were on a independent call
for service an illegal shooting and they
were standing out in front of the
residence that was associated with the
call uh having a conversation with the
resident
of that place and subsequently they had
shots fired upon them
um luckily they weren't hit um
and they were able to return fire and
get a good description of the suspect
and because of a good police work in the
proceeding 24 hours an individual
officer who had knowledge
of the description of the suspect was
able to locate him
and we obtained a confession
but a bigger picture is to your question
do we do we learn from these type of
incidents do we adjust our training so
they don't occur in the future
yes absolutely and you heard us talk
about the
reality-based training facility that
we're proposing
out in the northeast part of town so
officers
on these low frequency high risk events
we could put them in training scenarios
to adjust their
mo or how they respond to these type of
calls in the future
so they they meet them with success and
without getting harmed
uh it's important for us to learn from
our mistakes and
move forward from yeah i'm glad your
officers weren't hurt in that
allegiant stadium can now have a limited
number of fans some really good news
uh but sheriff a big question has been
parking so
when a game or event does happen how
will metro be enforcing traffic around
the stadium there's going to be a lot of
it
yeah um well here's um the only silver
lining of this pandemic
is is we've had ability to take our time
and ensure that we have proper protocols
in place
um to address these kind of situations
so the the traffic control company is a
private company that we partner with
to control the traffic in and out of the
stadium and this company is currently
contracted with t-mobile so they have
some experience working with us they
have some experience with the las vegas
community
and the ingress egress different routes
of
a big stadium like this so they put a
lot of protocols in place in partnership
with us
and and with it being a limited capacity
event
we'll be able to work all through all
the faults and nuances and everything
that you can imagine on a type of event
like this of its breadth and size
we can slowly work our way into it and
figure out where the
issues are with the people coming in and
out
so that was a long convoluted answer to
a simple problem
and the simple problem is we're used to
it we've done it the company we're
partnering with
has done it at other stadiums throughout
the united states
in particular to the nfl and i think
we'll meet success
uh with our plan yeah we'll be nice to
get fans in there too at some point all
right
sheriff thank you for being with us it
is great to see you you're welcome good
to see
you all right if you at home have a
question for sheriff joe lombardo
send it to us on our website
eightnewsnow.com and find out if your
question was answered
every wednesday